on l'appelle le caviar des Balkans en
condiment ou en tapenade live vert et la
recette parfaite pour préserver la
fraîcheur des poivrons toute l'année on
commence pour la première étape on fait
griller les poivrons natacha barthoulat
est né en Bosnie le River n'a pas de
secret pour elle traditionnellement
quand vous étiez petit on faisait ça
tous les automnes toutes les autres
temps et c'était des quantités énormes
donc là ici on a des aubergines des
poivrons rouges est-ce que vous mettez
d'autres légumes dans votre Rivers non
c'est tout on va mettre juste un peu de
l'ail ça prend beaucoup de patience
beaucoup d'amour surtout quand on fait
des quantités industrielles ma mère elle
a préparé une quantité de 50 kg là toute
la famille impliquée les enfants le mari
aussi et souvent les voisins aussi donc
ça me rappelle des bons moments donc
c'est une fête c'est une fête une
célébration
dans un quartier très résidentiel avec
des blocs de département et à l'OTAN les
gens ils faisaient routir leur poivrons
leurs tomates tous ensemble
Peter balove et bulgare il connaît bien
la tradition festive autour de la
préparation du Ivar qu'on connaît chez
lui sous le nom loup tennisa aujourd'hui
dans son bistrot de quartier il sert
plusieurs plats des Balkans et c'est un
des favoris de sa clientèle souvent les
recettes changent d'une région à une
autre même d'une famille à une autre
moi j'aime que ce soit très simple c'est
ce que bon j'ai appris de ma grand-mère
et ma mère au restaurant ici on utilise
un ratio de deux courants 2 kg de
poivrons rouges versus 100 kg de tomates
et un peu d'oignons
la recette et le nom de Live varie d'une
région à l'autre de lexio goslavie et
des Balkans
[Musique]
ça dépend dans quelle partie des Balkans
se situe et les normes change un petit
peu les recettes changent un petit peu
les épices changent un petit peu ça se
fait définitivement un petit peu en
Turquie pays d'où le nom
Ivar proviendrait puisqu'en fait le mot
turc aviar signifie œuf salé ou caviar
c'est comme ça qu'on veut nos piments il
est fait que on les fait cuire sur le
feu ça donne le meilleur goût un goût
fumé un peu
[Musique]
il est possible de trouver le Ivar dans
certains commerces spécialisés on trouve
des versions lisses comme un ketchup
alors que d'autres sont plus texturés
telle une relige des recettes légèrement
piquantes sont aussi offertes là Natacha
on est rendu à la partie satisfaisante
hachez tous ces beaux légumes ça il faut
faire les purées donc il faut le faire
vraiment mince c'est vraiment un belle
forme de purée donc ce qu'on veut c'est
sentir des morceaux et non un liquide
exactement on fait pas des smoothies
après qu'on est réduit tout ça en purée
c'est la cuisson
on met tout et on va le mettre sur le
feu naturellement déjà même avant la
cuisson je suis certaine que c'est bon
on a encore besoin beaucoup de patience
parce que il faut remuer constamment en
moins de à toi
[Musique]
j'aime comment vous le présentez donc
avec des fromages des olives donc on
peut être créatif définitivement on peut
être créative on peut aussi le manger
avec des viandes avec des frites on peut
le manger sur une tranche du pain avec
du beurre on en parle mais là on va
écouter
pour moi ça goûte l'automne c'est doux
c'est onctueux
la tomate et le poivron sont bien
balancés
[Musique]
ce que j'aime aussi c'est quand l'hiver
on sort ce qu'on a préparé à l'automne
et que les saveurs sont tellement
relevés c'est comme une récompense en
plein mois de février exactement
Natacha merci d'avoir partagé votre
recette mais aussi vous souvenir
d'enfance merci à vous à Sainte un grand
plaisir
[Musique]